Oh le menteur !
Non, mais c’est pas possible !
Alors là, c’est fort !
On peut avoir parfois l’impression que les
économistes disent n’importe quoi.
Et avec les crises économiques, tout particulièrement,
lorsque les choses vont mal, leur crédibilité
intellectuelle est atteinte.
Leurs déclarations passées sont épluchées,
et malheur à tous ceux qui n’avaient pas
vu venir la catastrophe !
Pour Galbraith, le problème ne tient pas
à l’économiste, mais à la discipline.
Je suis Romain, et vous êtes sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Alors, tout d’abord, qui est Galbraith ?
C’est un économiste américain décédé
en 2006, qui est connu pour avoir fait partie
du brain trust du président américain John
Fitzgerald Kennedy, ce groupes de conseillers
qui appartenaient à l’élite intellectuelle
et académique des États-Unis ;
mais aussi pour avoir conceptualisé la capacité
des entreprises à dicter aux consommateurs
leurs désirs, et l’émergence d’une classe
de gestionnaires, les managers ;
et enfin pour avoir écrit de bons ouvrages
de vulgarisation économique, notamment sur
la crise de 1929 et sur l’argent.
Mais Galbraith, c’était surtout un économiste
spécial à 2 titres :
il était un économiste plutôt littéraire,
au sens où il se méfiait beaucoup de la
mathématisation de la discipline
- et c’est pour ça que je l’aime bien
-
Galbraith était aussi spécial parce qu’il
était très critique à l’égard de l’économie.
D’après lui, il y aurait des énoncés
qui persistent au sein de la discipline ; qui
sont encore véhiculés et encore enseignés
malgré l’évidence de leur caractère mensonger.
Dans ce petit essai intitulé « Les mensonges
de l’économie », il affirme que les intérêts
financiers et le prestige intellectuel brouillent
la réalité et créent un décalage entre,
d’une part, les idées admises dans la discipline,
et d’autre part la réalité.
Voici quels sont, selon lui, les 7 plus gros
mensonges de l’économie.
Vous allez voir que les derniers vont vous
étonner.
Quand on veut désigner le système économique
des pays industrialisés, on ne parle plus
très souvent de « capitalisme » ;
on dit plutôt « libre entreprise », « social-démocratie
», ou « économie de marché ».
Ce faisant, pour Galbraith, on gomme à la
fois le passé peu reluisant des capitalistes,
et la puissance des grandes entreprises, grâce
à la connotation méliorative des mots « libre
», « social », et même « marché ».
En revanche, le mot « capitalisme » charrie
avec lui
i) la prédominance des propriétaires et
l’asservissement des ouvriers ;
ii) l’idée de monopole ;
iii) la dimension d’autodestruction du système
(les crises) ;
iv) et même, selon Galbraith, leur responsabilité
dans le déclenchement des guerres.
Ça fait beaucoup.
Mais surtout, ce premier mensonge est la source
d’un deuxième !
En parlant d’« économie de marché » plutôt
que de « capitalisme », on présuppose que
le système est comme une démocratie économique,
où c’est le consommateur qui aurait le
pouvoir, dans la mesure où il imposerait
ses désirs au producteur.
Or, pour Galbraith, rien n’est moins vrai.
C’est en vérité le producteur qui influence
et qui dirige la demande du consommateur.
Grâce au marketing, l'entreprise persuade
le consommateur de choisir son produit ; elle
le manipule pour faire naître un nouveau
besoin.
De fait, convaincre les consommateurs grâce
à de l’information ou du divertissement
est devenu une opération banale pour les
entreprises.
Mais c’est ignoré par les économistes
!
Du coup, Galbraith dit qu'il n’y a guère
que dans les écoles de commerce que l’économie
est proche de la réalité.
Là, je suis sûr à 200% qu’il n’a pas
fait une école de commerce.
Quoi de commun entre les tâches d'un ouvrier
dans une usine et la création d’un tableau
par un peintre ?
D’un côté, c’est répétitif, ingrat,
long, épuisant, etc.
et de l’autre, c’est créatif, enrichissant,
et gratifiant.
Et pourtant, on parle bien de « travail » dans
les deux cas.
Ça, pour Galbraith, c’est de la pure escroquerie
!
Alors, l’expérience du travail est différente
selon les personnes, mais pour la grande majorité
de la population,
le travail, c’est une activité forcée
par les nécessités les plus primaires de
l’existence.
C’est plus précisément une obligation
vitale pour les pauvres, tandis que les riches,
eux, s’en affranchissent et peuvent jouir
du loisir.
Pour illustrer cette vérité, Galbraith reprend
la citation de Keynes des mots gravés sur
la pierre tombale d’une femme de ménage
:
« Ne me pleurez pas, mes amis, ne me pleurez
pas, jamais, car je ne vais plus rien faire
pour l’éternité.
»
La mort l’a libérée du travail !
On assimile volontiers l’entreprise au risque
et à la libre initiative, mais ce sont surtout
des caractéristiques des PME et des entreprises
familiales.
Or, à partir d’une certaine taille, l’activité
économique de l’entreprise requiert une
gestion centralisée, c’est-à-dire une
bureaucratie.
Quand on entend « bureaucratie », on pense
URSS, administration
mais c’est également une réalité de l’entreprise
!
Comme le terme est connoté péjorativement,
on parle plutôt de « management », qui
fait plus dynamique.
D’un côté, la bureaucratie est bien sûr
nocive : elle ralentit, voire elle paralyse
l’action ; et puis elle tend à l’auto-expansion
: la bureaucratie appelle la bureaucratie
;
mais d’un autre côté, elle est bien nécessaire
pour donner toute son ampleur à l’innovation.
Galbraith lie la bureaucratisation de l’entreprise
à l’inversion du rapport de force entre
propriétaires et directeurs :
en dépit des apparences, ce seraient désormais
(il écrit au début des années 2000, mais
son intuition est antérieure)
ce seraient les managers qui auraient le pouvoir,
et non plus les actionnaires.
On oppose traditionnellement le secteur privé
et le secteur public.
C’est notamment le cas en France, où le
secteur public est important.
On distingue bien les entités qui relèvent
de l’un, et celles qui relèvent de l’autre
; on associe volontiers certaines propriétés
à l’un et à l’autre.
Or, pour Galbraith, si on regarde les choses
sérieusement, en réalité la distinction
public-privé n’existe pas.
Elle est de l’ordre du discours, pas du
réel.
Il donne l’exemple du rôle très important
du secteur privé DANS le secteur public aux
États-Unis :
l’influence de l’industrie de l’armement
dans la politique étrangère américaine,
par exemple ;
l’implication croissante de mercenaires
dans les guerres ;
ou encore l’impression qu’on peut avoir
que de grandes entreprises privées - comme
notamment Goldman Sachs
mais aussi d’autres - placent leurs pions
aux plus hauts postes de l’administration
fédérale américaine.
La question est soulevée aussi en France,
où les présidents Pompidou, et aujourd’hui
Macron, se sont vus reprochés d’être passés
par la banque Rothschild.
Étant donné que, des deux secteurs - qui
ne sont donc en réalité pas du tout imperméables
-
étant donné que c’est surtout le secteur
privé qui pénètre le secteur public, cela
introduit un biais caché, mais important,
dans l’action publique.
Pour Galbraith, les entreprises les plus puissantes
redéfinissent l’intérêt public pour l’adapter
à leurs capacités et à leurs besoins.
Selon lui, la politique économique, c’est-à-dire
l’action économique du gouvernement, est
aux antipodes de l’intérêt économique
général.
Par exemple, les réductions d’impôts n’auraient
pas l’effet de ruissellement par lequel
elles sont justifiées
elles ne bénéficieraient pas aux plus nécessiteux
-
pour Galbraith, il faudrait plutôt encourager
directement leur consommation, ce qui profiterait
à tout le monde.
De même, la protection de l'environnement,
qui relève évidemment de l’intérêt général
- puisqu’on habite tous la même Terre - est
négligée parce que les entreprises les plus
puissantes n’y trouvent pas leur compte
à court terme.
Mais l’exemple de corruption de la définition
de l’intérêt public sur lequel Galbraith
insiste, c’est l’influence du complexe
militaro-industriel - contre lequel le président
Eisenhower avait mis en garde les Américains.
En gros, l’industrie de l’armement tient
l’armée, laquelle pousse en faveur du déclenchement
de la guerre afin d’écouler le stock d’armes.
Bah oui, il faut une bonne guerre pour vendre
des armes !
Galbraith est assez cash : la finance est
pour lui « un univers bien connu pour ses
mensonges ».
Le principal est, selon lui, la prévisibilité
de l’économie.
En fait, comme la prévision est une activité
très appréciée et rémunérée, l’économiste
a surtout envie de faire plaisir à ses clients,
qui, eux, espèrent tirer un profit de ses
prévisions ;
et du coup, l’intérêt particulier supplante
l’objectivité scientifique ; l’espérance
ou le besoin l’emportent sur la réalité.
Dans les faits, explique Galbraith, Wall Street
rémunère grassement des économistes pour
qu’ils donnent une allure sophistiquée
à l’ignorance générale.
Galbraith dénonce donc la situation de conflit
d’intérêts des économistes de la finance,
situation qui les pousse à diffuser des « mensonges
».
Je résume : d’après Galbraith, il existe
donc 7 mythes - ou mensonges si on veut - en
économie :
1.
l’existence d’une forme de démocratie
économique ;
2.
la souveraineté du consommateur ;
3.
l’épanouissement par le travail ;
4.
l’absence de bureaucratie dans l’entreprise
;
5.
la distinction secteur privé ≠ secteur
public ;
6.
l’intérêt public ;
7.
la rationalité des fondements de la finance.
Alors, on peut reprocher à Galbraith d’être
un peu excessif en parlant de « mythe », ou
de « mensonge » ; mais sur le fond, ce qu’il
avance me semble très intelligent et très
solide.
Après, ce qu’un économiste pourrait lui
rétorquer, c’est qu’il arrive forcément
à l’économie de dire des bêtises parce
que, comme toute discipline qui se veut scientifique,
elle progresse vers la vérité par essai
et erreur, c’est-à-dire par corrections
successives.
L’adage latin dit « Errare humanum est,
perseverare diabolicum », ce qui signifie
« L’erreur est humaine, c’est l’entêtement
qui est diabolique.
».
Enfin, pour ce qui est des situations de conflit
d’intérêts, ce n’est pas un problème
propre à l’économie :
pensez par exemple à la médecine et à l’industrie
agroalimentaire, ou encore à la climatologie
et à l’industrie pétrolière.
Mais bon, grâce à Galbraith, les économistes
peuvent rentrer dans le droit chemin.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, mettez un pouce
bleu et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire ma synthèse de ce petit livre,
Les mensonges de l'économie de John Kenneth
Galbraith sur le site 1000 idées de culture
générale, voire pour pour lire l’essai
directement, les liens sont dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisées dans le format le
plus clair possible, vous pouvez vous inscrire
à la newsletter en laissant votre adresse
e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain et sous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous vous n’avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.